I hate intros haikyuu season two we'd
kick things off right after the lust
alibi Joe sigh and everybody is back to
training
Tonica comes in to let everybody know
that they are planning on going to Tokyo
to attend a training camp the camp is
held by the bukuvu o'donneii Academy and
only a couple of select schools are
invited victimized in the group and
luckily got kata suno in the camp as
well leader while I'm exercising Hinata
and Kageyama got lost and end up running
into
Ujima from sheet authorities Aoi Academy
things get a little tense when he
doesn't acknowledge them as a threat so
Hinata flexes a little and they vow to
beat him
everybody is also trying to ignore the
fact that final exams are coming up but
they need to do well in order to go to
Tokyo episode 2 oh the first years are
trying their best to get their grades up
before the trip to Tokyo meanwhile the
third years are gonna be gone after this
year so Kyoko is trying to find a first
year to replace her as manager she is
able to recruit heat okay yeah Qi who
was shy and kind of intimidated by how
intense the players are what GUI ki toka
is in advanced classes so she helps
Hinata and Kageyama with their studies
in the last scene we also find that
Tonica also accepted a last-minute
practice match against ogen is she high
school episode three agony she is no
match as they lose the cat Asuna 25 to
16 in the second set P toka is still
trying to decide if she wants to become
an official manager as she is still just
in the trial run her mom says not to do
what if she can't match their passion
which makes her hesitate but after
talking with Hinata about it given
scissor to tell her mom how she feels
she is able to break her timid persona
and confidently tells her mom that she
is going to be joining as the manager
episode 4 everybody arrives in Tokyo to
start the training camp well almost
everybody Hinata and Kageyama had failed
so they have to attend supplementary
exams for a part of the first day of
camp they finish early and Ryunosuke
sister Socko Tonica gives them a ride to
Tokyo meanwhile kata soon know try their
best to keep up without their power duo
and we meet the other teams
participating we have UBA gawe high
school who are known for delivering some
unstoppable serves mixed is shinsen high
school who have very strong synchronized
attacks of course kata soon is rival
mahai and their new player from the ova
lev hiya who is becoming a real threat
yes we have Foucault dou Donny Academy
who are one of the stronger teams in
Tokyo and they're a Scotto bokuto
is in the top five aces in the nation
god I certa have lost nine sets in a row
on the first day but once Hinata and
Kageyama arrive they turn things around
winning the last set against shinsen II
episode 5 the next day their first
matches against mecca mode working not
says insane quick gets shut down by Lev
he wants to continue getting stronger
and decides the best way to do that is
to open his eyes during the free quick
up until this point he would just close
his eyes and Kageyama would put the ball
where it needed to be so that he could
spike it if he is able to open his eyes
he could accurately aim the ball the
problem is how fast it quick happens
which doesn't leave him much time to
react everybody seems to be against this
idea as it will be hard to learn and the
spring prelims are just around the
corner they leave the camp but will be
returning one last time during summer
break when they get back to kata soon oh
he got two tries to learn how to
implement his idea into his play but
fails and ends up getting into a fight
with Kageyama Episode six with Hinata
feeling like he's hit a roadblock in his
practice case Shane takes him to get
guidance from his grandfather and coach
of the little giant ek Oh Kai he tells
him out of that he's going to have to
learn how to hit different kinds of
quicks at different tempos meanwhile Kay
Xin once Kageyama to learn how to set
the ball so that its momentum dies out
right as it enters he not to strike
range they aren't the only ones working
though nishinoya
notice how of a Joe sighs Lee Berto was
also doing sets when Owen kaua couldn't
so he wants to learn how to do that to
both Aussie he and Yamaguchi are working
on their surfs to become more of a
threat in that aspect episode 7 they
head back to Tokyo and Facebook Udo
Donny Academy again there are some
serious changes going on in the team
with everybody trying to implement what
they've been learning it's still pretty
scuffed but the evolution of the team is
apparent to everyone the only one who
doesn't appear to be working that heart
is soo Kashima and they wonder if it has
something to do with his older brother
who played with the little giant
episode 8 this episode revolves around
Fukushima and we learned that his
brother tried really hard to get better
and become a starter a caddis uno even
with all the effort he put in he wasn't
good enough to become a starter and was
ashamed because of this Fukushima is
scared of ending up like his brother so
he doesn't try as hard not seeing
incentive to he ask some of the other
players why they are so determined and
some choice words from coat ATO ignites
his determination to improve episode 9
who do tell us is still not working out
in kata sudo is getting obliterated and
the majority of their matches
Kageyama decides to practice by himself
so he not too goes to practice with
co-taught oh he learns a lot about
notches powering through defenders but
instead using faints and wipes to out
finesse them the next day we see the
match wins for the teams with who koto
Donny leading the pack only losing 14
out of 64 matches goddesu no have one
more match against boo koto Donny before
they camp comes to a close so they are
determined to make it a good one episode
10 finally the hard work that cada suno
had been putting into their new play
styles is starting to bear fruit
everything from synchronized attacks
Asik he serves sets from nishinoya it's
all improving at an insane rate for the
first time Kageyama and he not to nail
the new quick stunning everybody however
this was only one time and the next
attempt fails miserably as the matches
kept close Kotaro starts to lose his
cool and plays worse eventually going
into his infamous emo mode
episode 11 brew Coto Donny are used to
playing around the Aces emo mode so they
pick up the pace to give him time to
recover this takes the attention off of
him and he comes out of nowhere to score
the winning point ending the final match
of the camp 25 to 23 in favor of kukuda
Donny points back from Tokyo we take a
look at the prelims where cata soon I'll
have to win two games in order to go to
the qualifiers for nationals
the qualifiers will decide the
representative of the Miyagi Prefecture
which is their main goal the episode
well the day of the prelims arrived and
kata suno have their first match against
og Minami of course they're not going to
lose to some random team that came out
of nowhere it's pretty filler esque and
they win in the second sight with the
score being 25 to 13 their second
matches against cop Kagawa high and
basically they have a really tall dude
named you die he akazawa episode 13 yeah
cuz now uh proves to be a thorn in their
side after he scores over their block
and shuts down he not too spanked
although he's tall that's really the
only thing he has going for him as he
lacks technique and experience got a
sooner get all their techniques rolling
and Hinata wins the second set with a
wife which is where he purposely hits
the defenders hand to score off of the
bounds
episode 14 they made it through the
prelims so now everybody is training for
the qualifiers Fukushima goes to
practice with his brother against older
stronger opponents to learn how to
defend against someone bigger than you
like he akazawa we get a look at how but
Jos eye as they get a returning member
can't a Tokyo tani who's like Kageyama
in the sense that he's really good but
has poor team skills meanwhile kata
cirno head back to Tokyo to practice
more with nekima and the other school
skewing a training montage we're gonna
go ahead and jump past the montage to
the first day of the qualifiers where
kata soo no squares off against Jose ng
hi in the first round yep so 15 as the
match starts it becomes apparent that
what makes Jose ng strong is their
unpredictability making it hard to know
where the attacks are coming from they
have a very light-hearted approach to
the game and just seems to be having fun
and goofing around after losing the
first set and falling behind in the
second set Jose ng still don't take
things too seriously their man
Ahana Misaki has to step in and for the
first time tries to make that crazy team
concentrate this seems to be effective
and the team takes on a new form
episode 16 Jules ng seem to be
reinvigorated and give kata Sunna a run
for their money they stop trying to
block Hinata - instead try to receive
the spike giving him the opportunity to
practice his accuracy even though they
try to make a comeback Jose Angie still
can't compare to kata suno so they lose
in the end advancing kata suno to the
quarterfinals the mix match finishes and
waka Thani south advances meaning that's
who kata suno is gonna be playing gym -
the second day where the match starts
and their captain Nakashima stays calm
in the face of their new quick answering
back with points of his own this is
turning into a battle of the captains
but in the last scene died she gets her
after diving for a ball
episode 17 well going for the ball died
she had collided with Ryo nosegay and is
forced to go to the infirmary by the
coaches who is replaced by chika
diagnosed ax and if you don't remember
him that's fine because neither did I
he's no Daiichi but he does well enough
and it turns into a side character
appreciation episode when Yamaguchi is
brought in also as a pinch server his
first serve almost fails as it hits the
net but barely makes it over bringing
them to match point for the second serve
he panties out and doesn't do his
jumping serve while also freezing under
the pressure when the ball comes to him
even though they win off of the play he
is yelled at for not giving it his all
episode 18 bear still stuck with the
budget captain while died she is
recovering and they lose the second set
because of this in the third set and no
shita makes a big play and seems to be
more comfortable after that it comes
right down to the wire but kata Sunna
are able to pull out the win despite
their captain being afk after the match
both an OSHA and Yamaguchi recognize
that they need to train harder to keep
up with everybody else
well everyone watches as Dante tech
takes on our Bajau side to decide who
kata suno plays next
episode 19 today Tech is experimenting
with a new center named kanji Kogan
Agora which isn't going so well although
their offense is struggling the iron
wall defense still stands strong they
lose the first set and continue
struggling in the second set Oh match
point the alba josiah ace [ __ ] mate UI
zoomy punches a hole straight through
the iron wall winning the match
this means that kata suno get their
rematch against our Bajau sai and oikawa
episode 20 goddess uno have a much
easier time dealing with alba joe side
this time around fixing a lot of
mistakes they made in the past game
against them its neck and neck
throughout the entire first set with
each side countering the others tactics
when cata suno gets to match point alba
josiah brings in their returning member
kenthoi doe on the next play Quintero
knocks one of his teammates out of the
way but lets loose a fierce spike that
catches everybody off guard II episode
21 luckily the killer spike was out so
cata sunna win the first set but at the
start of the second set Kintaro is
starting on the first play he runs
parallel to the net to get an insane cut
past the defenders
Kentaro is the embodiment of a
double-edged sword sometimes failing
miserably but working enough to put cata
sunna behind they bring in sugawara and
he targets kentaro with his serve so he
can't be the one to spike good catch on
to this pretty fast and adjusts so the
next curveball that case Sheen wants to
try to break their momentum is to put in
Yamaguchi
episode 22 Yamaguchi had been working on
his serve constantly and now that he is
controlling his nerves better he is
nailing them every time this serves
catch them all the way back up tying
both teams at 23 the two teams trade
points back and forth until eventually
oil cow was nasty serves tips the scales
allowing our Bajau side to win the set
28 to 26 with each team having taken his
set they head into the third and final
set to decide the match and who goes on
to the finals yep Izzo 23 as the third
set progresses a long Ryunosuke starts
to get inside Kent Otto's head knocking
him off his game it even gets to the
point where Kent Otto is benched to let
him rest and calm down one of his
teammates she guru Yabba sets Kintaro
straight to get him back in the game
he's back to operating a pole
capacity but the same can be said about
the deadly duo who still aren't lighting
up episode 24 again the third set is
super close ending up getting tied at 20
very burned in Yamaguchi for the second
time and hopes that he can repeat his
success on his previous serves he it's a
really good serve that almost messes up
Kent Otto again but they managed to save
it and shut out any more possible serves
boy cow was serves on the other hand are
still getting through and bring cow but
Jo side to match point at 24 to 22 the
captain of kata suno Daiichi steps up
and manages to put a stop to a cow was
served keeping him in the game at 23 to
24 they put in sugawara who makes some
big plays followed up by Kageyama
scoring putting kata suno at match point
at 25 to 20 for the last volley is a
long one with both sides making clutch
saves but in the end Hinata is the one
to put it away and end our Bajau sized
run in the qualifiers this also marks
the first time that Kageyama had beat
his old upperclassman mentor episode 25
goddess uno is now in the finals where
they will have to go against the
defending champs in cheetah Tori's away
Academy when they get back to school a
bunch of the students are waiting to
congratulate them including daichi's
waifu what better way to end a long day
of volleyball than with some more
volleyball videos practice gets
interrupted and they are forced to go
home to get some rest because tomorrow
everything will be decided in the finals
I'm gonna be doing the future seasons
and that'll be in the bottom up don't
ever I'm finished with that or you can
check out all the haikyuu recaps in this
playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
outros